all right everyone good morning again um
now we're going to have another talk on
achieving developer autonomy on
on-premise data clustering using uh
kubernets uh this is a talk from one of
our sponsors Adan uh so Yori is going to
walk through us through the whole
process and yeah let's see what uh
questions we can get all right uh I was
expecting an empty room but this is very
different from what I expected so uh
yeah good to have have you all here and
thanks P data for inviting me um yeah so
I'm York slicer I'm data platform
engineer at aen uh I've been working
there for almost three years and in my
spare time I play a little bit of tennis
and padel so uh if you want to play pel
in oven then hit me up because uh that's
where I'm
from um yeah so this is the table of
contents this a very important slide I
was told but uh yeah we have 87 more
slides to ago so let's uh let's go what
does aen do aen is a payment provider
and these are our customers and they all
believe that aen provides a unique
product that gives them a Competitive
Edge over their competitors and you'll
probably know quite some of them Spotify
McDonald's who doesn't like their
hamburgers uh Subway and the single
people probably no Tinder all the way at
the bottom um yeah so a lot of
customers and that also means that we
don't just do data but we do Big Data um
and one important detail to this is that
we do everything on premise so that
means that we own a servers ourselves
and when a hard drive goes Bust or when
a CPU goes bust we actually have someone
that replaces that hard drive or
replaces that
CPU um yeah furthermore we're also doing
everything open source and that
definitely limits Us in uh what we can
do compared to when you're on the
cloud uh let's go into the teams and
responsibility so how is aen build up
first of all we need someone that
actually manages the server so these are
the infastructure teams and these are
the ones that have root access to the
machines because everyone knows it's not
a good idea to give 3,000 employees
access to uh to all the servers with
root so that's why we have dedicated
teams that uh that manage the
servers then we have the tooling teams
that's what I'm a part of uh here we
have the data platform Engineers data
engineers and they install the tools on
the machines uh together with the
infrastructure teams so stuff like spark
uh other
apis um yeah so and they really try to
help out the product teams as much as
possible to achieve their goals and the
product teams consist out of the data
scientist data Engineers data analysts
and these are ones that generate
insights uh for our business or for our
customers uh the ones that create
machine learning models to detect fraud
uh We've also had a presentation from
from our colleagues yesterday uh how we
use graphing databases to detect
fraud um yeah so that's kind of how it's
built up and that also shows in terms of
the number of people at the at the top
we really have only one team that helps
us out on the big data side so that's
around 15 people then we have four
tooling teams and we have 20 plus
product
teams but when you look at the waiting
game when we want to install a new
software let's say we want to change a
configuration in airflow or we want some
years ago we introduced ml flow then
what happens is the tooling teams does
all the research but then at some point
you want to install it on the machine
and that's where you need the
infrastructure team and of course they
have a lot of things on their plate they
don't just do big data they manage all
the servers so there's a lot of uh or
sorry not all the servers they manage a
lot of other servers as well um so
anytime we knock on on the door there
was a little bit of waiting
time but what happens when the product
teams want to introduce new stuff like
dask or they want a fancy streamlit app
which is uh the new way to visualize
your
insights then oh
sorry then they'd have to come to us
we'd help them out but then again we'd
also have to wait for the infrastructure
team to again deploy the things on the
machines this all takes a long time can
I get a show of hands of whom of you are
on the
cloud all right that's a lot of people
uh yeah it's it's really is a magical
place right with a click click of a
button you have a storage layer that can
hold pedabytes of storage um with an API
call you can spin up a spark notebook or
when you need analytical queries just
another button and you have a presto
cluster up and running and it really is
amazing so it really blows my mind but
right we are not on the cloud and now
anytime we deploy a new application we
go through this waiting game now let me
show you how many applications we
actually have of course we have spark
then to actually launch our uh spark
batch jobs we have
yarn um then we have HFS for
storage we also have juper Hub huh it's
appearing on the screen but not on my
MacBook so that's
weird um then we have
airflow uh to schedule dos then we have
ml flow tsor flow PGE signup CML XG
boost light GBM dusk trino Druid po
grass Cal elastic search dreamlit puppet
anible El up kros Hive Apachi Ranger
that's a lot of waiting and that's a lot
of tools right so yeah something had to
change because we can't just be Reliant
and waiting every single time we want to
do a single
change so the goal is really a CH
achieving higher velocity and we want to
do that by giving more autonomy to all
the developer teams so that includes the
product teams and the tooling teams the
product teams want to introduce new
tools by themselves so stuff like flight
or streamlit and the tooling teams this
want more autonomy in managing the
applications they already have and also
possibly introducing new applications so
anytime I want to change the
configuration in airf flow then I don't
want to go knock on somebody else's door
I want to do it myself
so this required us to make quite some
changes and the first change was we
wanted to be able to deploy any
application with each and this is where
the resource orchestrator comes in which
we'll dis uh discuss
next we also wanted to deploy any change
automatically because everybody knows if
you deploy it manually you'll forget
stuff so that's why we're going to talk
about gith UPS then we want to be able
to update our application without
infrastructure approval while sort of
keeping us safe and environment that's
where multi tency comes
in and then we want to connect the
different applications together that we
are creating uh and this is where you
often use secrets to connect them
together so we needed a decent secret
management and finally we wanted to
migrate our current
applications so yeah what is a resource
orchestrator a resource orchestrator uh
schedules your jobs on your server so
let's imagine you have five servers well
actually at aend we have tons of servers
but let's just get back to this example
with five um so we have five and we want
to create a a report so this is spark
job and it's a very small report so this
can just be launched on a single server
again next report comes along can also
be spawned on the single server then the
third report comes along and now it
tries to schedule it on the first server
but the resource orchestrator will know
this server is already packed with jobs
uh this can be scheduled there so it
will schedule it
to the next
server now when a big job comes in so a
very large report then we need to
distribute the workload across the
servers and this is also the job of the
research orchestrator so a single one
won't work instead we schedule it to all
three
servers um and now preferably we don't
just want to be talking about about
reports and Spark jobs and dok jobs but
we also want to run any arbitrary
application so just any sort of
container like ml
flow um yeah but unfortunately as you
might have seen on the previous slot
slides we use Hadoop yarn as a resource
orchestrator and that doesn't really uh
work for uh the above mentioned case
because anytime you want to run a
specific application you need to install
it on the servers and that means that
some way or the other you have to SSH
into the machine to install it and that
requires the someone from infrastructure
to do it furthermore it can just run any
sort of application it can only run
batch
jobs uh and the community has mostly
moved on and that means that when
there's an issue that would mean we'd
have a really hard time finding someone
that can help us out um also new tools
they don't support yarn out of the box
they support kubernetes out of the box
so yeah yarn doesn't really was or yarn
wasn't really a good fit for us but what
were the options we considered we kind
of had three options the first one was
yarn so to keep using the tools we
currently had but that's not really a
great option for us second one was
switching to kubernetes and the last one
was switching to hasor Nomad can I get a
show off hands of the people who've ever
heard of hasor
nomad all right that's that's quite a
few people still so for the ones that
don't know aror Nomad is like a
kubernetes alternative they approach
things a little bit differently and it
might work better for your use case or
less in our case we already had Nomad
clusters in uh in aen but still we
decided to go with kubernetes because
all of the tools for Big Data they come
out of the box with kubernetes support
so it doesn't make sense to us for us to
spend months on rewriting Nomad
Integrations for every new tool we want
to integrate so yeah that's why we went
for
kubernetes and now the first question
you have to ask yourself when you're on
premise which is not something you ask
yourself when you're when you're on the
cloud is what youber need this
distribution do you use and actually
there are tons of them and these are
just the ones like the first 20 I took
of a list of
60 um so you probably know a couple of
these uh like we have Google we have
Azure AWS Alibaba digital ocean while
all of these are cloud provider
distributions so you need to be on that
specific Cloud to use it so we can
remove those then we have a lot of them
remaining and yeah I can take the one
with a ketchup bottle logo seriously so
let's remove that one as well and then
we looked because we're a payments
company it needs to be very secure so we
looked at all the options and then
there's one that really uh shines out
and this is
rca2 this is the distribution that's
also approved by the US government to be
used uh not yeah well that made us uh
believe it's more secure as well so uh
that's why we went with RKA
2 so how do developers deploy their
yamos okay so right we have this
kubernetes uh cluster now it's running
R2 um and the next step is how can we
deploy the applications that we want to
deploy well there are multiple options
here the first thing is the devel Vel
oper does it himself and that's not
really great because this guy is
laughing right now but when he leaves
the company in a year he doesn't tell
you about all the manual hacks he did to
get these applications up and running
and that will mean that when he's left
the company so does all the applications
he introduced because you need to redo
everything um then there's the second
option cicd where you uh run pipelines
to automatically deploy to your cluster
and then the last option is giops and
giops is more something listening on
your branch uh on your git repository
and then deploying it on the kubernetes
cluster so the difference between cicd
and giops is cicd is push based so you
have some pipeline pushing the code to
cuber Cluster where the gitops is
constantly pulling the git repository
for changes and then applies it on the
kubernetes cluster and usually this
gitops uh tools also run inside the
kubernetes
cluster you also have tags and branches
with cicd where with giops you usually
really use only a single branch and with
cicd you have uh you when you revert
your work you might also have to retack
where with pure gitops you really only
have to do a revert of your commit so
for us it was a pretty easy decision we
really likeed Argo CD so we had a happy
octopus uh what does it look like when
you deploy some uh
manifest so in the background here I am
typing a new commit new application just
a very simple web server and then I make
the commit Argo CD is refreshing the
branch it noticed there was a change and
boom before you know it it's deployed so
what we have over here is at the top we
have a service uh then we have a
deployment and then finally we have an
Ingress and Argo CD what it just did is
it loaded the branch in it saw all the
kubernetes manifested needed to the
deploy it checks whether they're already
deployed resolves it and then uh deploys
the
changes all right and now you might
wonder this is really cool tool but does
this mean that developers can update
whatever they want or do you use some
sort of multi tendency then the question
might be what is multi tendency because
uh it's not a very known
word well what we Define first is we
have a user and this case it's a team so
a team inside
aen and they get a name space for a
single application and they would deploy
that on a kubernetes cluster so what you
see on the cloud usually is that every
team spins up their own kubernetes
cluster because spinning up a cuber need
cluster is really cheap um and then they
have a couple name spaces per team
because they have different applications
that each team manages and where with uh
multi-tenancy you strive more towards
sharing this single resource which in
this case is the kuber unit cluster
across the different teams so that
doesn't mean we only have one kubernetes
cluster with an end we have like 20 plus
actually um but one kubernetes cluster
serves many different teams without them
uh being able to sort of screw up the
other person's work or the other teams
work all right so how do we set these
boundaries for the
developer well first of all Let's uh
recap this infrastructure and developer
uh split off so on the infrastructure
they provide the kubernetes cluster and
they maintain the storage layer so they
maintain hdfs for us and they manage and
enable the tenants meaning when a new
team comes along and they want a new
name space they create that namespace
for
them furthermore the developers they
just want to deploy their applications
and their tools and and they can do
whatever they want as long as they stay
within the boundaries set by
infrastructure so what does this look
like in practice we have two separate
repositories we have the infrastructure
repository and the developer repository
where on the infrastructure repository
we specify all the security sensitive
items so these are things like firewalls
which are called Network policies and
kubernetes also the required security
settings for containers so that the
containers don't run with rout Access
Control resource limits you name it
anything security sensitive is in that
repository furthermore we also have all
these Argo CD applications so these are
the things where you define in Argo CD
what you want to be deployed in each
namespace um so it sort of um points to
a git branch and then it will resolve
that git Branch to that
namespace so these are all defined
inside the infrastructure repository and
also the boundaries of that Argo CD
application so in there we specify what
can be deployed by that argocd
application so all these security
sensitive items you see at the top these
cannot be deployed by the argocd
application that's sort of pointing to
the developer
rapo furthermore any change we make here
has to be reviewed by the infrastructure
team on the other side on the developer
side we can deploy or we have the
application manifest and we can deploy
whatever right so we deploy spark or we
have the Manifest there for the spark
jobs we have the Manifest for hoisting a
mail flow we have the Manifest for air
flow and
then um these are automatically deployed
by the Argo CD
application and the reviews are done by
the team itself so now anytime I want to
make a configuration change to airflow I
can just go ahead make the change and
somebody from my team can approve it and
then boom it's automatically
deployed so what does this look like in
practice uh here we have the
infrastructure argd
application at the top we have some
storage limits saying that you can't use
more than two terabytes for this
namespace uh we Define a nam space we
have the quota uh meaning not more than
this CPU not more than this memory uh
and at the bottom we have the
firewalls and in the middle you'll see
you have this tenant Argo CD application
and when we click on it you see that we
get back to the project that I deployed
earlier right and now you may wonder
what happens when one of our employees
turns
evil well okay maybe not that evil
um yeah what happens when a de tries to
make himself an admin so I tried this
and I tried to deploy a cluster role
binding which would give myself uh admin
privileges to the entire cluster which
would mean I would be able to delete and
deploy whatever I want and as you can
see Argo CD has this yellow ghost object
here here that uh it's trying to deploy
this resource but it can't because it's
not allowed and if you look uh further
and you click some buttons you see that
the Sync has filed for this specific
resource because this cluster roll
binding object is not permitted in this
Argo CD project so thereby we're really
limiting off what the developer can
deploy okay now we have the applications
uh the developer can deploy whatever but
now if we want to connect applications
together and we want to use some secrets
that's where secret management comes in
and what is that
like so again we are open source we're
on premise so that considerably limits
are options because every cloud has
their own secret manager um we had some
requirements that Secrets should be
accessible from multiple places without
copy pasting them around and we didn't
want developers to be bothered with
encrypting secrets in the
repository uh because that also does
really feel like a nice
experience so what we came up with was
using hasor Vault with the external
Secrets operator on
kubernetes uh and the flow looks as
follows we have a team that creates an
MR on gitlab to request some Secrets uh
inside their
namespace and then we have this tool
called Atlantis that constantly watches
this repository and as soon as this mrr
is approved and the U original author
says apply Atlantis will take mrr it
will apply it to theault and merge it
and then from that moment on that
namespace has access to all the secrets
and now what we need to do is actually
get the secret in there so the team they
create a resource inside
kubernetes um which uh is an external
Secrets resource and there it simply
asks for the secret from uh fault and
then the external Secrets operator will
fetch it from The Vault and create the
secret for
you and and this is very nice because uh
in this fash we still kind of have
infrastructure reviewing which Nam
spaces get access to which secrets so
that's uh still a security layer there
and it makes it very easy for us to
share the same secret between name
spaces whenever that's
needed okay then on to the final part so
what were our migration efforts
like um so I think a very good uh IDE
for us was to start with applications
that were widely used but not critical
because you don't want to use an
application that is not that much used
that you only notice five weeks later
that's been broken for the past five
weeks you will really want something
that problems are noticed immediately
but it's not critical so if it goes down
for two hours that should be okay that's
why we chose to go with trino and Spark
history server where trino serves all of
our analytical queries and Spark history
server contains the history of our spark
jobs right
um but we also had some new PC's which
were Cassandra and data Hub and this
really allowed us to see how the
kubernetes cluster was functioning and
immediately gave us some insights mostly
insights in things that we were missing
because we were definitely missing some
monitoring we were missing some logging
um monitoring I'm just talking about
metrics with logging I'm talking about
the moment you created deployment and
you deleted and create a new deployment
you lost all the logs from your
historical deployment uh um so that's
why we needed to also step over game
there and mostly connectivity because
connectivity between pots uh or between
nodes isn't that obvious because uh
that's where it didn't really go so well
we had a small dumpster fire
there because aen is quite big and we
deploy our firewalls in a centralized
way and that also meant that the
firewalls were being deployed to the
kubernetes nodes but what that means is
that the moment you spin up a pod and
you override those firewalls it also
overrides the network policies that are
just applied on the cuber needes cluster
meaning you will lose all connectivity
from those
spots um so yeah trino and Spark history
server went down uh couple times uh but
luckily it was only these applications
so otherwise we would have had a real
major fire if we already migrated
everything and only then we discovered
it yeah so the winds we really improved
in uh time to Market we are able to
deploy new applications in a in a matter
of hours instead of days or even
weeks um also when people want to
experiment they want to try something
new they can just create an MR deploy it
within the same team and it's much
faster um also developer autonomy now
when I want to change the configuration
I really can do it myself instead of
constantly knocking on someone else's
door to make the configuration change
for me and finally security which is
definitely very important for us um it
also improved a lot because the
firewalls got even more even stricter it
used to be that we deployed firewalls on
a server by server basis but now we can
really limit those Network policies or
firewalls per
application uh because multiple
applications might be running on the
same server right so that's why that's
important for us and also secret
management improved a lot because when
multiple applications are running on the
same server these applications can
access each other a secret if they go
Rogue uh and now the secrets are really
contained within the name space so you
can only access uh the application can
only access its own
Secrets all right uh then short summary
yeah it shows you how we move to
Containers using kubernetes how we
wanted to go for automatic deployments
of yaml how we manage our secrets and
and how this allowed us to uh achieve
developer autonomy and uh yeah some tips
for migration if you uh want to connect
here are my socials and uh well before I
end thanks to all my colleagues uh I
didn't like the slide was uh already
very big I didn't list everyone but
these are definitely some of the people
that uh helped out during this effort so
thanks to all of my colleagues and the
entire team uh yeah
cheers